this is how much mhmm its journey from
Syria to safety cost after getting to
Turkey Cometh stayed at a hotel for
eight nights then he paid a smuggler to
get him across the sea to lesbos for he
stayed in a tent for eight days then
spent a night in an Athens hotel then
Mehmet took a train across Macedonia
before spending three days crossing
Serbia Hamid then took a taxi from the
border to Hungary's capital Budapest
then a train to Vienna Austria and one
last train to Salzburg before a free bus
to the German border add the cost of
food SIM cards and other expenses
twenty-two days seven countries two
thousand five hundred and fifty five
dollars